Welcome back.
I hope you're refreshed after importing
your first libGDX project and
I'm sure you're dying to learn how to
create those sweet particle effects.
Before we get to that, though, we should
start out with some simpler drawing.
So in this level we're first going to
learn a bit about about how the computer
drawing pipe line works.
With a brief detour into color theory,
and how your eyeballs work.
Then we'll talk about the main
entry point into libGDX games,
the Application Listener Interface.
We'll implement an application listener,
and then use ShapeRenderer to draw some
simple shapes, some pretty flowers and
even some fancy fractals.
Let's get started.